[Music]  remember all the dances we had in this  gym  ever wish you could go back i sure do  going to bayside is going to change our  lives hey buddy  you're an honors english yeah it's an  honor to teach me  these bayside kids weren't exactly  raised to have a killer instinct i have  a kardashian coming at lunch  who rob shut up he's still in their  family  is it just me or the seniors at the  school really old looking hey jamie  heard you talking about the harvest  dance it's just you  [Applause]  i have way too much on my plate there's  a way to increase productivity  are those caffeine pills at first  they're so exciting and then  it gets even more exciting but after  that it gets so scary and in the end you  ruin your girl group  shot at a recording contract what  you